sus vías urinarias incluyen los riñones
los uréteres
la vejiga y la uretra
sus riñones producen orina que fluye a
través de los uréteres hasta su vejiga
su vejiga se expande para almacenar
orina hasta que esté listo para orinar
los músculos llamados esfínteres se
contraen para retener la orina en la
vejiga
cuando orina los esfínteres se relajan
esto permite que la orina salga de su
cuerpo a través de la uretra
los músculos fuertes del piso pélvico
sostienen la vejiga y otros órganos para
que funcionen correctamente
la incontinencia urinaria de esfuerzo
significa que la orina se escapa por
accidente cuando un movimiento ejerce
una presión repentina sobre la vejiga
puede suceder cuando usted 12 ríe
estornuda o hace ejercicio la orina se
puede filtrar si los esfínteres o los
músculos del piso pélvico están débiles
los factores que pueden debilitar estos
músculos son el parto la obesidad el
envejecimiento y la cirugía pélvica
para obtener más información sobre la
incontinencia urinaria de esfuerzo hablé
con su proveedor de atención médica